here's the big story Elon Musk tweeted
reinstate former president Trump yes no
well as you can see I voted yes of
course and there's just about 800 000
votes in uh what are we looking at like
20 minutes just to shy of 20 minutes
62 percent say yes 38 30 say no and uh I
kind of I find it kind of silly like why
is a former president whether he's
allowed to speak in the public Town
Square being brought up to just like a
poll from the CEO is kind of a weird
thing it seems very strange especially
given this is supposed to be how Twitter
operates going forward like do we get to
vote on everyone from now on I would
probably use Twitter if this was the
Democratic process
well unfortunately then you can have
very likely to invoke mob roll kind of
stuff uh marble consensus of people can
then just get together and it's just the
way that anything Works in terms of
banning people from other sites you get
a group of people together you incite
them into saying oh we need to mass
report demand the Twitter remove this
person or vice versa demand that they
reinstate somebody so
democratizing Twitter can be potentially
harmful in its own way who the hell
would have thought that the former
president of the United States who's
running to be the next president of the
United States is is is having his future
of his speech being determined by by
freaking Twitter poll that absolutely
makes no sense at all it's absolutely
ridiculous and it it really shows you
how Elon Musk is really failing here
he's not doing a good job he should make
a strong decision he should make a
decision that is based on principles not
on Mob Rule and that's essentially what
he's depending on here which is
ridiculous I think Elon is this strange
character because we especially
conservatives want to Rally around him
he says interesting things things that
we feel like are right but also he
doesn't operate a hundred percent by
conservative values and he doesn't hide
it right like Tesla is the from what I
understand the only car company that
operates without a state-owned partner
in China why is that why is he permitted
that right it's just one of these things
you mean like he operates in China and
he's not being controlled by the state
or whatever yeah so it's not like you're
saying all car companies in the U.S work
with China so all car companies if you
want to manufacture in China again I'm
not an expert but this is what I've been
reading about it
um they have a partner to help them with
their distribution and Manufacturing
China Tesla is the only car company that
operates without this kind of
partnership the car companies in China
are owned by the Chinese government why
is Tesla allowed to do this I I think
Elon Musk is a really interesting
character but I am not surprised that
he's not always consistent right we like
Free Speech but also we have a poll for
the president like that seems strange
yeah I think he saw that he could make
money from this
I think that's really it I think he
likes the Babylon bee I think he saw an
opportunity to make money because
it seems clear when you're active on
Twitter that the majority of people want
jokes want to have fun but you can't and
what was happening is slowly over time
Twitter was being compressed into a
really boring and awful space and it was
resulting in I mean here's what I think
elon's like why are there so many
competitors to Twitter emerging why is
Twitter losing so many customers and
it's because they're censoring everybody
he probably thought you know I'll buy it
uncensor some of the people and then you
know we'll make we'll we'll make it more
valuable and then we'll turn it public
again that's what he said he was going
to do so of course he's saying [ __ ] he's
doing a poll to reinstate Trump why
because he wants to see what people on
Twitter actually think and if and it's
kind of smart we're up to 932 000 votes
62 say yes and that's probably where
it's going to be because if he's like
the overwhelming majority of people want
him on the platform then I'm going to
service the customers
still weak absolutely weak I don't know
what's going on with the audio is the
audio okay or is it fine what's going on
I feel like it's fine I don't know if
it's something it's exactly the same as
was when I started so I don't know yeah
but okay but anyway it's still weak it's
still extremely disappointing you you
make a decision if you're going to be
standing by free speech that means
standing by that decision and nothing
else again I don't know do we have the
audio fixed yes okay you can keep
talking and I'm just I'm distracted with
all of them
uh yeah that's always muted everything's
fine yeah I don't know okay that's all I
had to say I just feel like Elon Musk
knows that he's ultimately
um trading in public popularity right so
it I don't actually know and he could be
a devout Free Speech purist he loves it
but he recognizes that in modern
application it has to be limited in some
capacity I don't really know what his
philosophy on this is I just know that
he's inconsistent in a lot of ways and I
as much as I want to admire the things
that he's done that are good I feel like
we all have to take it with a grain of
salt and remember that like he is
ultimately
serving himself as far as we know we
don't know what the end of that is I
think he's running it like a CEO like
he's run everything else so ultimately
the way he's looking at Twitter is
what's going to be most profitable if he
ends up getting a huge mass of people
who actually do leave Twitter and manage
to force themselves away from it because
Donald Trump is back on there sending
out mean tweets or because Alex Jones is
out there existing then maybe that's why
he's decided against that unilaterally
well because it's clearly about the
money so he did now oh yeah you want to
read it Hannah
I'm sorry you don't even know my name
Luke I've known you for so long I said
Hannah I think you have to read it
that's not like no no yes it is sorry
you have an address and then I was like
Claire they said box popular Vox day
Elon Musk
have they figured out the Bots have they
figured out the fake accounts on on this
particular platform because again that
was a major topic of discussion with
Elon Musk previously talking about how
many people were gaming the system
manipulating this this this big Tech
social media platform to the point where
of course A lot of the stuff was
illegitimate so how how do we know that
this this poll is actually going to be
legitimate how do we know that other
systems other people other groups won't
be gaming this Poll for their own
personal benefit uh which still hasn't
been cleared up to how many accounts are
real how many accounts are fake how is
this platform being used for the
Sinister purposes of a lot of powerful
people that's a question that I think a
lot of people are still waiting to be
answered that might never be answered
because we're still waiting to find out
what's going on here and if if Elon Musk
is just taking this approach just to
make money it's not going to be
incentivized for him to be honest with
the people about how many people are
fake on the platform no and I would say
that's what is Twitter blue doing
nothing but you know putting certain
people forward it's just being a little
bit more honest about it than Twitter's
been in the past that it's what you're
going to see because you pay us for it
and there are people who are so addicted
to Twitter that they will I think
probably stay there and keep doing at
least for the time being they they
created this this rumor last night that
Twitter was going to shut down and it's
very clever organizing on the part of
the left basically the idea is make
people fear they're going to lose their
follower their their followers ships or
whatever and then you'll get them to
leave the platform and so they do
they say oh no no Twitter's going to
shut down by tomorrow quick and then
everyone says everyone quick follow me
on Mastodon and they're trying to create
a a surge a tsunami an inflection point
where enough people jump ship that
they'll actually start using the other
platform I wouldn't suggest Mastodon for
people on the left it's totally uh you
know unfederated or de-federated so
there's no moderating on Mastodon people
can use very naughty nasty words that
you certainly couldn't use on Twitter on
Amazon you can't you can't censor them
or whatever
um I'm sure there's something they ban
anything that's illegal in Germany
apparently uh I know that when there was
a big Twitter surge or you know they
were all these hashtags moved them or
like Twitter Exodus a couple weeks ago
and then immediately they moved to
Macedon and couldn't believe all the
racial slurs and anti-Semitism and then
they were like oh no my safe space so um
yeah it was really funny but that's
about it I mean that's the reality of a
decentralized network they're not going
to have the resources of a major
corporation so this is what you get
I don't know I just don't trust Twitter
I never trusted it before I don't trust
it now that elon's there I know that
it's sort of a a personality thing some
people live or die but I really feel
like in some ways like I'm on it
professionally to get news releases as
they come out because so many people
have converted it into this you know
tool for the pr
um but I don't I don't trust Elon Musk
like if this is how we decide who gets
to be on Twitter I don't want to be
there anyways right if it's like if
you're more concerned about double
verification like
verifying anybody who pays money is the
stupidest idea maybe he thought people
wanted it so bad that he was going to
make a ton of money right away from it I
feel like this whole rollout has been
just really really bad like Elon you
either go for it or you don't there's no
half measures you think I'm gonna pay
eight bucks like I'm I'm inclined to
actually cancel the so we signed up
timcast news for Twitter blue for the
verification for the most part and
because it's a new account and we wanted
to have access to like filters or
whatever and also I want I want Twitter
to succeed I want I want it to work with
what Elon is doing I want to believe
that when you know when he reinstates
some of these people we saw last week
some people got reinstated all right all
that's really good and then he and then
he and then he he comes out and he's
just like I don't know with all this
stuff basically I'm kind of just okay
all right now I'm not entirely convinced
we're going to see this this platform
get fixed so here's here's my mindset
now
I'm not I'm not rooting against Elon on
this stuff I'm I'm looking forward to
some improvements but uh I'm gonna lean
back a little bit you know I was I was I
was leaning back last week or two weeks
ago then we heard last week that he had
reinstated some accounts and I was like
okay so it looks like he is going to
start improving things and I said okay
you know I'll get Twitter blue but I'll
get it only for Tim guesters I'm not
going to buy for my personal just yet
we'll see what happens
now we have this and I'm kind of like
do you think Elon could have done more
with a uh secondary platform like if he
had taken over not truths necessarily
but like some other things this is the
one thing that Ian is very very wrong
about all the time freeing the code
Twitter's code is garbage it's nothing
their algorithm sure I guess I agree
with Ian insofar as free the code so
that we can know what the algorithm is
doing to us because it's manipulating us
but gab parlor getter Minds The the
ability to input text and have a server
output it to a person who decides to
follow a number like
not hard to do yeah so what Elon bought
was you and me and Luke and Aiden and
serge he bought all of you at home who
use the platform it's a community of
people having control over that is
useful how do you you if you launch a
new Twitter how do you get people to use
it you can't because what makes Twitter
valuable is that people are there it is
downtown
so you can buy a little store in the
suburbs I guess getting people to show
up there's gonna be a lot harder so this
is what Elon really wanted thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time